excellent let's begin i might have to
grab my copy after the game
speed run day 18 000 we are over 2100
let us begin
okay mr nwa oh he's a sub to my channel
okay let's go d4 uh i've mostly been
playing e4 but i do want to play d4 in
this term by the way is the audio
quality okay
i'm not using my mic right now if it's
if it's uh grainy then i'll i'll bring
my mic
okay it's fine okay so c4
uh and he is playing the king's indian
defense
ladies and gentlemen we are playing now
against the king's indian
okay so what do i recommend
to players in the 2100 rating range
against the king's indian
i recommend the sameish variation and
to those of you who are not familiar
with it i will explain it in detail
after the game the same-ish
uh is denoted by the move f3 what is the
idea of f3
well you guys have might have seen this
move before on the sicilian what is the
idea
who can tell me what white's next move
is andrew tang by the way is a
specialist in this line
well we're cementing the pawn on e4 what
move do we follow this up with
so well we don't play d5 that's that's a
little premature what we do
well we develop our bishop to e3 yes h4
is ultimately going to be the idea
the sameish is the only line in the
king's indian where white
usually castles queenside now you could
castle queenside in other lines
but in this line that is sort of the
main line theory
so typically we play f3 for two reasons
we cement our central control number two
we stop him from harassing our bishop
with knight g4 that's very important
knight g4 as you guys know can be a very
nasty move in these positions
and we don't want to give away this
bishop unless it's
for this bishop so what our opponent has
done is gotten kind of an accelerated
dragon type structure
and um this is not the best way to
respond against the same ish now white
is just
solidly better i've got now a positional
advantage on top of my tactical
advantage
so how should we continue yeah queen d2
is good here we could have also dropped
our knight back to c2
to prevent the trade but the trade isn't
bad for us and one very important
decision that
as white we're gonna have to make here
i've talked many times
about flexibility what you have to be
able to do at a high level
is begin the game with one plan
but stop on a dime and shoot a
three-pointer you were planning to make
a layup
now you're gonna shoot a three-pointer
what that translates to is
the ability to let's say castle short
and say you know what now we have a
positional advantage we're not going to
go for the immediate checkmate anymore
but
rookie is a bit of an empty move and
because rookie 8 is a bit of an empty
move
i'm going to allow myself to castle long
and we're making our intentions
perfectly clear
i am going to go for his throat in very
conventional fashion
h4h5 open up that h file and go for
checkmate we've done this before in
openings such as the perk
okay let's go uh there's no need to
delay let's go h4 we're of course going
to sacrifice that pawn that's the whole
point of this attack
um is he well okay what would be the
russian
school of chesma in this kind of
position who can tell me what the
russian school of chess move would be
so the russian school of chess would be
king b1 right king b1
as many of you guys know is a very
healthy move to play
in uh positions where you've castled
long why do you play it
you play it uh and let's actually play
it you play it because this king is just
a lot safer on the b file if black puts
a rook on c you guys can see how
if the king remittle there we go prophet
if only we had a prophecy okay now i
will assure you that the attack
will proceed a lot more smoothly now
that the king is
safe the king is not globally safe it's
just that we've bought ourselves some
time
it's harder to get to this king and
we're going to have more time
ourselves for the orchestration of the
king side attack now we've got to be
very careful here what should we do who
can
tell me the move here
so there's a little bit of a wrinkle
here because
if we go g4 and we say get the hell out
of h5
where can the knight go black has a very
nasty response to that
black is a very nasty yeah knight g3 is
very nasty because it attacks the rook
and he might take the bishop so in the
spirit of
preparing slowly and attacking fast
here's what we're going to do
we're going to drop our knight back to
b3 uh
basically i'm reducing the tension on
the d4 square i'll explain this in more
detail after the game
i'm forcing the queen to move and
depending on where the queen moves i'm
either gonna
uh you know proactively defend the g3
square
to prepare g4 or uh if the queen moves
to if the queen moves elsewhere uh we
might even sacrifice
the exchange on h5 or we might go bishop
h6
i don't know if this move makes sense to
people what we're essentially doing is
eliminating
this tension on the d4 square so that we
can as they say in russian
untie our hands to attack
with a in more single-minded fashion on
the king side right
we don't have to worry about all these
trades let's see where he goes also
we're forcing uh
oh robert lost that sucks
i mean robert and i partners in crime
and
we've experienced some pain in this
tournament
damn that's that's very sad
robin robert and i are gonna cry
together okay so if he takes on c3 then
we take back
and we've eliminated his most important
piece even at the cost of our pawn
structure that's more than worth it
uh but let's focus on the game guys
so yeah playing on both sides of the
board so is everything i'm doing so far
making sense there's a lot going on in
this position i know that some of you
guys are feeling a little bit
overwhelmed
so much going on we've sacrificed upon
but fundamentally uh
the battle is revolving around who
checkmates which side first right we're
going on the king's side our opponent's
going on the queen side there's nothing
mysterious about that nor should there
be
and this gets my alarm bells going
because one thing that people forget to
do just because a move didn't work
at some point doesn't mean it doesn't
work now so let's consider the move g4
g4 knight g3 but because the queen has
repositioned itself to the center where
it's maximally vulnerable
what move becomes possible after g4
knight g3
bingo stefan selmar
chess bishop f4 forks the queen and the
knight
now it's sort of a fake fork because he
can take on f1
and attack our queen but remember what
was our initial goal our initial goal
wasn't to win anything it was just to
get rid of that knight
so that we could again untie our hands
so that we can finally
reposition our own queen to the h file
and deliver checkmate along h2 we are a
lot closer to our goal
than our opponent is to doing anything
to our queen side our queen side is
still completely intact
and aren't you guys thankful that we got
our king away from that c file so we
don't have to worry about any of that
crap
now here comes queen h2 here's johnny
and now it's big time trouble for black
because queen takes h7
while that's not checkmate immediately
it's going to be checkmate in just a
couple moves
so black does have ways of staving off
the mate but in my estimation
we have so many pieces now geared toward
the king side we're gonna made him in a
couple of moves here
black can hold out for a little bit but
he's busted and also the queen is
is very bad here it's just stuck in the
middle of nowhere
okay now there's a very very typical
idea
i want everybody to remember queen h8
would be checkmate
but wait a minute it's not checkmate
because there's a bishop here
next question in our mind can we get rid
of that bishop yes we can we can go
bishop h6
and we natured is still checkmate
because of the pin
simple attacking game and
he didn't even touch our king our pawn
structure remained completely attacked i
didn't even play this perfectly
um i think i made a couple inaccuracies
but it was good enough to win
so the same ish with f3
right um when was this move first played
i'd like to give you guys a little
context
as to when these moves were first played
to give you a little historical
knowledge remember that the king's
indian
didn't really gain prominence until the
1920s 30s
when the hyper modernist came around
people did experiment with it in the
1800s but they're mostly left
laughed at it was first played in the
year 1925 by samich
so the same issue is one of those
openings which is actually named for the
guy who played it first friedrich
i think he was austrian uh grand master
in later life
very strong player one of the leading
players in the world really in the 20s
30s 40s
and he played it twice in 1925 and 1926
and then um yeah and then it was played
throughout the 20s 30s it gained
prominence very very quickly samis
played
a lot a lot of same issues wait wait i'm
not showing anything
no no i'm just i'm just talking about it
guys guys guys relax
i'm just talking about it i'm not
actually showing any moves
i was just saying when it was first
played um
so just to recap what is the idea of the
sandwich two ideas number one
we protect the pawn on e4 remember what
i said about
uh playing against opening such as the
king city it's not about the amount of
the center that you control
it's about how well you control it so
it's very important to make sure that
our central pawns are well protected by
our pieces and other pawns
so that's why we play these two moves
our bishop protects the d-pawn our pawn
protects the e-pawn
and relax then relax and we of course
prepare to castle
long and go h4h5 c5 actually happens to
be
one of the best lines this is a again
but this is a pawn sacrifice
and taking the pawn is possible but it
leads to
some wild complications uh black is
actually fine here i'm not gonna delve
into the detail just
trust me uh this is fine for black
that's why we left this a lot
and c takes d4 was i would say a pretty
serious inaccuracy
um the reason it is in inaccuracy is
because it
it allows us to get this kind of morozi
bind it releases the tension
and instead of this knight c6 would have
kept the tension
and applied pressure on the d-pawn and
the thing is that if we go d5
uh where can this knight now migrate to
and i've told you guys this logical
thinking many times when a pawn
advances in the center the immediate
question you want to ask yourself which
squares are now
weakened it's e5 yeah it's e5 well
knight d4 would blunder the pawn
right one two three i would just take it
twice so
knight e5 would be the move attack in
the pawn now the theory goes knight c1
and black can strike in the center with
these kicks this is kind of a benoni
style way of playing
there is a lot of theory here welcome in
there's a lot of theory here
so uh we're not going to delve into this
but c takes d4
gives us a pretty easy life i would say
knight takes d4
2 and here we decided to cancel law
if he had gone bishop d7 if he had gone
bishop d7
we would have probably gone bishop b2
and castled short which would result in
kind of a morozy bind
like position that we've had actually
with the black with the black side uh
because we played the accelerated dragon
sorry but rookie is kind of a waste of
time so we cast along
and we begin the attack h4 and now king
b1
so does this move make sense to
everybody um i i want this the the
idea behind king b1 to make sense is it
absolutely necessary to play this move
could we have also considered h5
absolutely this is a judgment call this
isn't like an obligatory move
but it's a good idea to play this if you
do have the time for it because
you might be thankful later also if the
attack
you know fails and you screw up
you might have that insurance of having
the king on a safer square which would
buy you more time later in the game
yeah that's sad so now we go h5
sacrificing the pawn and here was the
critical moment in the game
why not knight b3 that would have also
been good by the way i considered it
queen before though would have been a
little bit pesky and you can't go a3
because
you wonder the knight so i was um
slightly concerned about this
now why couldn't we play g4
well the problem here is knight g3 as i
explained attacking the rook
and if the rook moves away then black
takes the bishop and you might look at
this and say well what's the big deal we
give up the bishop
no nbd no big deal but the problem isn't
actually
that black has taken the bishop what is
the problem in this position
uh i'm looking here for a very subtle
observation actually
um i'm looking for a subtle observation
about
the way that white has rearranged his
position now first of all c4 is
very weak and black can attack this but
there's another observation
yes metropolitan i'd gift you a sup for
that
queen can't be in front of the rook okay
and in this position it's very important
for the queen to lead the attack because
if you
have it the other way around it's not
that this isn't strong but this isn't
checkmate
and it'll take you a while you have to
get another rook to the h file then you
have to move the first trick away
this is a lot more cumbersome than
having the queen in front as we saw
so this move knight g3 really shakes
things up on the king side and not in a
good way
that's why we go knight b3 first of all
thank you aquila gifting to metropolitan
and now after queen e5 we go g4
using the queen in order to force him to
give up the knight for the bishop
okay so rook d takes f1 and now
we nh2 repositioning the queen why
didn't he take a rock because then he
loses his queen
right we attack his queen and his knight
this is a fork so we would have won his
queen and then we would have come back
around for the night
um the their black did have a way to
stave off checkmate
and he could have done that by playing
h5 forcing white
to get a pawn on the hval but this this
pawn is not going to remain there for
very long we're just going to
take on g6 and because black hasn't even
gotten the engine
started on the queen side uh there's no
doubt in my mind that this would result
in checkmate
okay yeah 985 is also a pretty good move
uh that's also a theoretical line
so no that's just the cars
how could black of defender from mate so
this is the way to stave it off but not
for very long
um so any questions about the way in
which we conducted this attack
i mean i can show you guys just by a
chest-based search
a million games where the attack
succeeded precisely in this way in the
same
ish it's incredibly common to have an
attack
end with checkmate along the h file
precisely in this manner let me actually
do a little
a little search and see what i can find
isn't rookie 8 good because it yeah so
that's tranquil see that's the idea but
but it's to it's simply too slow um and
in the dragon by the way that's another
opening in which
you often get this kind of attack so
here's a good example one moment
just looking well here's a here's a
moment from
a game of julio sedora grand master from
dallas texas um watch what he does
so let me reposition this to a
chess-based scene
basically we join in a samish
this is the same as julio sador against
tyler hughes strong player
and watch what julio does in this
position so he buys himself some time
here's bishop h6 trying to trade the
bishop black dips his bishop away to h8
and now julio after taking the pawn
orchestrates a very strong maneuver
what is white's ultimate goal in this
position what does white want to achieve
ultimately like what is on white's wish
list and if you paid attention to my
game
you would know what particular thing
i'll check
well how do we get mate what will be
necessary queen in front of the rook so
we want the queen on h2
now watch what julio does bishop c4
paving the way
for the queen but he doesn't go
immediately to h2 first he clears the
path by moving the bishop away
now he still doesn't go queen h2 he's a
little bit worried about this knight
getting loose
so he moves the knight away sacrificing
the other knight
and now he goes queen h2 and after
rookie six
how does white deliver checkmate by
force in a couple of moves
white to play and deliver checkmate i'm
going to grab my coffee as you guys are
thinking
this concept pattern recognition is
thrown out a lot this is what pattern
recognition is mark baretzky the famous
chess trainer
even recommended for his students to
have a notebook where they literally
wrote down
all of these patterns they would cut out
diagrams and glue them into the notebook
and this would be a collection of
tactical themes this is one such theme
this is how you get better at attacking
in your openings by learning concepts
like these now you guys will not forget
this idea of trading bishops
the queen on h7 and if black have gone
king e8 that would have been nominally
more resilient
but i guess bishop takes b5 would have
happened and now
we transform the advantage and win the
queen black decided to just let julio
give checkmate
no it's it's no no he saw this he was
just being graceful
um allowing julio to check me of course
he saw this tyler is a very strong
player actually
okay so let's play e4 this time
showcasing the whole
range of repertoire and this time
well let's continue playing shall we
continue playing the alopen or shall we
switch things up a little bit let's
switch things up let's play the open
sitzillion
let's play the openstack we've been
playing the alpine mostly but
i'm sensitive actually no let's play the
moscow
and this is a line which flies under the
radar
it causes a lot of people to roll their
eyes but it's actually very venomous
and take my word for this bishop i've
checked this is called the moscow
variation
okay so now we castle
and the moscow variation is sort of like
a morozy bind against
d6 more rootsy bind of course is mostly
played against the accelerator he goes
queen takes d7
now yeah we definitely will so what is
the
perk of what we what we're doing we have
not yet put a knight on c3
everybody sees that right uh how can we
use that to our advantage
why you know why is it a good thing and
we haven't put our knight on c3 yet
what move will we be able to play so we
can play c3 d4 but in the spirit of the
marotzi bind we can also play c4
and grab more of the center but first
we're going to play d4 thank you river
right
first we're going to play d4 now we're
going to capture with our queen and now
we're finally ready to play c4
and clamp down on the center the queen
can slide back to d3
protecting both of these and our plan in
such a position
is going to be very clearly defined
we've talked about this scenario many
many times
what is white's plan here what square do
we want to access and how do we access
it this is the smithslav idea
i've shown you that smith's love game
many times so this particular
stock idea should be very obvious but do
we go 95 immediately
do we go knight d5 immediately how do we
get a knight there so that it's not
captured
you guys are pointing to the right
square but we have to do something for
bingo
g5 bishop g5 then we take the knight
then we put our knight on d5 that is
like the classic
plan and we don't have to rush with
bishop f6 that's another mistake
that people make rushing uh if the
knight
leaves then he does our job for us right
we can just put our knight on e5
so one good thing that we can do to
increase the pressure is to put the rook
on d1
so that once we take on f6 we we can
potentially also win the pawn on d6
okay but let's first attend to what he's
doing so he's putting the queen on the c
file what i think he wants to do maybe
is go bishop e6
so a good idea here would be to do what
how do we like
basically tell him this queen ain't the
boss this queen is not the boss
whoa bartholomew with a raid thank you
john hey guys
you go rook ac1 now we've talked
at several points we're doing the
speedrun you guys coming a great time
thank you guys
lost today painful game but trying to
recover by
doing some speed run and uh really
appreciate everybody's support reptilius
thank you for the sub
okay so now we can complete our plan
bishop takes f6
but here's the thing this is what i just
said um
we don't have to rush with this move um
and actually in many ways
it's much more painful to the opponent
when we twist the knife in without
actually playing the move the threat is
stronger than its execution so let's
improve our position to the maximum
first
let's see how he defends and then okay
so bishop g4 is really good both
let's chase the bishop away yeah so
that's a typical mistake
he thinks that he's one upon he has one
upon
but what is he not foreseen guess what
ladies and gentlemen we put a rook on c1
there was a reason we did that
okay now this is where things get a
little bit attacked we have a beautiful
move here
here's the thing if we move our rook up
to c2 what's the problem the problem is
that he goes queen takes c4
and our rook is undefended which means
we cannot move the knight from c3 but
what we can do
we notice that the queen and the king
are on forkable squares programmed to
win thank you
knight d5 you cannot capture the rook
because of the fork tactics like these
is why you want to solve consistently uh
to see stuff like this
how do you see this well it's the fact
that the queen and the king are on a
forkable square and you have a knight
that's those factors should set the
metal detector off
if it's programmed well now we can move
the rook away
what is our plan going to be here
there's several ways that we can go
about twisting the knife in further
because i'm feeling pretty pretty
aggressive okay so he kind of does our
workforce f5 is just a blunder we're
just going to take that i mean e4 is not
dangerous at all
we're just going to move our queen away
he has no play and look at our beautiful
knight here
that knight is supervising the entire
board it is
dominating everything and he is in no
position to be opening the position up
he's literally doing our work for us
okay what should we do what should we do
here should we take on f6
no what should we do where should we
move the rook
bingo we're threatening oh and now we
have a sexy move
now we have a move that will be on
everyone's tinder bio
f6 interception tactic f6 and
intercepting oh this guy is going to pay
in
blood fossils in the juicer
what should we do now let's twist in
that knife
think about think of it this way what
weaknesses does this move create
let's think logically let's think
logically
okay it creates a weakness on the g6
square
now we can play 97 and win a bunch of
material but more elegant
would be to play this move trying to get
to g6
here's my point guys the knight is so
strong
but it's actually not even worth giving
the night up for an exchange 97 would
probably be even the best move
objectively but i want to emphasize that
it's not all about material
outposts are so freaking strong that
sometimes
we want to keep them even in the face of
the possibility winning material
if he takes our rook we check made him
on g7 fossilize
queen f5 is fine yeah but king h7 we
have rook takes g5
and because of the pin our rook gets
into the attack the game is over
well as i explained so if he goes king
h7 queen f5 would be equivalent we we
have rook takes
g by and and if he takes
uh well he can't take okay and now we
don't need to give a check
a lot of people here i know are tempted
with the check don't give the check
because he he covers up with his bishop
instead keep your eyes on the prize we
take the pawn
the point is not to win upon the point
is that the g5 pawn is going to be our
access point
to his king and we've now ensured that
that pawn has no other pawn defenders
now it's going to be easier to win
it's going to be easier to win takes g5
pin and win
thank you one good shirt appreciate the
tier one
so very thematic attack we're not doing
anything crazy we're just involving our
pieces
and i want to make it clear that many
roads lead to athens as
peter likes to say many roads many roads
lead to rome
when you're attacking uh there isn't
only one method in many positions
sometimes there is going to be plenty of
others now finally
finally we've set the table we've made
all of the necessary improvements
let's now actually focus on winning
material let's go knight f6 jack
okay why do i do this now and not before
because now we basically
you know we've completely disrobed his
king
and we can transform our our advantage
by just taking a million pawns
f f f okay sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry i'm i'm correcting it guys i'm
correcting it
i got it i'm correcting it i'm
correcting it i'm correcting it
okay there we go
you know it's a funny effect when once i
once i say it
um okay so if we d5 trades queens and
i'm just going to show you guys what
happened in the last couple of games
couple of moves um people were following
in their head i think
okay so now we're just going to win by
pushing this pawn forward paul's daddy
think for the prime
and d7 and now rook f5
pinning bishop we're going to take on f6
and promote with d8 queen
now guys i do see when people say pro
the moment
the board is frozen i immediately reset
it
now this last part of the game we played
knight f6 jack winning
the exchange of course remember he's
pinned and then we simply took his pawn
forced the queen trade and won the end
king very simple game
uh we didn't do anything extraordinary
this is the moscow variation
and the way that he played it we go d4
now why don't we go c4 immediately who
can tell me why
it's important to play d4 first what is
the drawback of playing super what can
black now do
to prevent us from expanding in the
center well black can play this annoying
movie five
and and we get this pair of weak squares
on devops this is a reasonable structure
thank you paul's daddy gifting to alex
dora but it's not what i wanted i want i
want the merodzia bind
and we get it and if you're black here
you need to immediately try to chip away
at
at the uh at white's bind
right you can't allow um you cannot
allow white to expand fully to develop
fully that's exactly what happened in
the game you saw the result so what
should black do here to chip away
at white's bind this is theory by the
way this is the only way i think for
black to equalize and that's the move b5
if you play the sicilian these moves
need to be second nature you need to be
able to play these
moves relatively automatically and
i actually can retain the pod by playing
b3 i know some of you guys are thinking
of that like what's the issue
but first of all black's bishop gets a
nice development square and second of
all
if black trades on c4 this pawn becomes
isolated
and this pawn can be accessed via the c
file so black at least gets some active
chances
in relation to white's pawns on c4 and
e4
you see what i'm saying well no queen
takes would not be very good because
that would walk into like something like
d5
and white does want to keep the blind so
i would still do this but the position
would be double edged
now again i cannot emphasize this game
enough guys i've shown you many many
times
smithslav against rutakovsky this game
is shown
to russian school children when they're
still in their mother's womb
and there's a very good reason for that
because this is one of the most typical
positional plans
known to man and it never gets old
because of how important it is
how ubiquitous and transferable it is to
so many different types of positions
um this is literally i mean i've known
this game
for i don't know how long um and and
i've shown it to all my students i've
shown it
many many times and as as
stale as it is there's a reason why it's
still this is this game's miss
gloverdakovsky1945
what did white do in this position
somebody remind me
white does not go knight t5 right white
goes bishop g5
takes the knight and puts a knight on d5
this is the typical method of
establishing a knight in the outpost
this has been done to me many many times
even in my own chess career i have i
have been the recipient
i have been on the receiving end of this
plan so transferring this back to the
speed run we literally do the exact same
thing bishop g5
but there's one difference we don't need
to rush with bishop takes f6
right uh the knight's not going anywhere
it is literally pinned so we first make
an improvement to the position by
x-raying his queen and only after he
plays h6 wasting time
sorry one second so rook ft1 bringing
our other rook into the game
bishop g4 now
basically here uh there were a couple of
tactical moments we could have gotten
knight d5
but instead i decided to get his bishop
to move
he takes on f3 thinking ah i won the
pawn but that's why we put the rook on
c1
we go knight t5 that's actually similar
to what smithslav did
it's more frozen no it's not and
the fact of the matter is if he takes on
a2 we trans
we transfer the attack right we now give
up our knight but we're simply gonna
checkmate him very easily
that's another thing i want people to
notice uh
people tend to be to fall in love with
their pieces when we have a nine and an
outpost that night can be used as a
bargaining chip right you can
use that night and give it away for the
greater good you
just because it's a beautiful night
doesn't mean you want to keep it there
forever
there are things that will that will
require you to give this knight away
that's fundamentally why you put it put
it there chess is a game or you have to
learn how to transform your advantages
and now knight d5 was the key mode
knight t5 is a small tactic if bishop
takes c1 we win the queen
right and now we get space for our rook
to move in the pawn is no longer
decked in f5 was just panic um
doesn't the queen take the c2 yeah but
why does a fork on c7
so what is an outpost i i think there's
formal definitions but
i like to think of it informally an
outpost is a square
now i would say statistically mostly
occupied by knight but an outpost can be
for any piece
even upon um and usually it's in the
enemy territory so
think of this part of the board an
outpost is a square in this territory
where a piece is supported by your pawns
and
to my eye the main defining factor of an
outpost
the piece has to be unassailable which
is to say no opposing pawn
can chase away that piece all right no
opposing pawn can chase away that piece
so if you were to reposition black's
pawn to e7
you were to reposition it from e5 to e7
this would no longer be considered an
outpost
because black would play e6 and chase
away the knight that is
what i would call the defining factor
here that's why the knight is so good
in russia they call it the eternal
knight now he panics and gives away the
pawn and loses quickly
what would have been our plan had he not
done that
well what i would propose is to double
on the g file
and then dislodge the bishop with g4
when the attack on the g7 pawn would
have been
completely unstoppable okay
um outpost target a large area well yeah
can you have a bad outpost yes you can
have a vehicle
coin uh coin you can have a bad outpost
um not all outposts are good but i think
the connotation
of an outpost is that it is good right
um you could
invent a bad outpost but if you're
talking about outpost that usually means
you're proud of that piece
yes so i would consider it an outpost
even if the bishop could have sailed the
night
um that's still an outpost i would say
that it's the limit test is whether a
pawn can chase away
the outpost well no black is basically
busting here because
because of the night i've lost many
games like this i
have been in many situations like this
with the black pieces
and it's not fun gotta kamsky once beat
me precisely
in a position like this crushed me on
the king's side on the g file actually
in a game that was eerily reminiscent of
how we beat this guy
the problem is when you get a knight
like that on d5 no matter who you are
whether you're a gm or
you know what you're rating is you lose
without a fight because
it's so hard to manufacture to
manufacture uh
chances so if you take a look at the
following position
yeah so this is from my game against
gotta camp scheme you guys can see
the similarities are eerie knight on d5
outpost
and um he crushes me here because black
has absolutely no play i'm just going to
run through the game
gotta runs his pawn up to v6 and what he
basically does
is uh he gives up that knight you see
what i said earlier
in precisely the way that i described he
gives it up in order to ruin my king
side pawn structure
and the advantage transforms from a
positional one to a tactical one
the knight has given itself up to open
the g file and now
you know fittingly the game ends when he
gets his rook to the g file unstoppable
right so this is exactly what i mean
when i say transform the advantage uh
there's more to talk about and unpack
here but i want to move on
let's get the next camera rolling
what is it about outposts that make them
so strong yeah it's mostly about the
cramping
and also they control don't overthink it
like we're just controlling a million
squares
like the knight in the center controls
eight squares mathematically but
it exerts its pressure over essentially
all parts of the board
okay so let's move on next game
hope you guys are enjoying um the games
have become more complicated but
my hope is that you know trying to make
this understandable still
even to beginners
you